[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle saison de
paf bienvenue aux téléspectateurs de tv
78 d internet bienvenues aux auditeurs
de radio sensations qui nous suivent
également eh ben on va essayer comme
d'habitude d'éclairer l'actualité de
l'explicité et on va parler notamment
aujourd'hui beaucoup de la démocratie
est ce que la démocratie est en danger
vous savez qu'il ya plus de 30 millions
de français qui sont abstenus aux
dernières élections alors qu'est ce que
c'est une démocratie où plus d'un
électeur sur deux ne se rend pas aux
urnes nous allons parler avec nos
invités avec bruno biais de bourges ou
bonjour vous êtes député modem des
yvelines et voulons c'est
un club de réflexion on peut dire ça
comme ça c'est une tendance en france en
ont va en français dans un club de
réflexion oui pour essayer de
réconcilier un petit peu les gens avec
l'action politique je dis pas les
politiques mais l'action politique
d'accord florence mercadé choqué bonjour
mon jean patry est avocat au barreau de
versailles je vais présenter dans un
instant ceux qui sont avec nous en visio
mais sur le plateau alors il ya
justement trois jeunes militants ils
sont eux engagés dans la vie politique
wandrille de kerpel bonjour bonjour
merci bonsoir vous êtes étudiant en
droit vous êtes membre de l air si vous
êtes aussi engagé dans génération z
c'est à dire le vous êtes même le
responsable de génération z dans les
yvelines c'est ce mouvement qui appelle
à la candidature d'eric zemmour et
longtemps des mers bonjour alors vous
n'êtes pas n'est pas la musique et à
vous êtes au parti communiste
et vous êtes
conseiller municipal de guyancourt et
puis avec nos visuels un autre
un autre étudiant phoenix deltour
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes vous
êtes versailles et vous êtes membres et
militants de l air m tout à fait je suis
consultant en communication et non
l'étudiant c'est vrai oui pardon vous
travaillez vous déjà exclue et bien
comme consultant en communication comme
communicante en tout quatre ânes
perdriau bonjour bonjour patrice n êtes
donc comme unique objectif en scène
conseillère régionale d'ile-de-france et
vous êtes proche de valérie pécresse
et puis jean charles lajoie dit vous
êtes éditeur toujours bonjour et vous
suivez l'actualité avec passion
alors on va on va commencer justement
c'est le 16 septembre que ça va être
confiée aux
confluences l'idée est venue après les
élections régionales en fait que c'est
moi j'ai été absolument
choquée de l'abstention si on se doute
que sur des élections intermédiaires
l'abstention est souvent forte mais à ce
point là c'est énorme 70% des gens qui
ne se rendent pas leurs
ccc n'avais jamais vu ça et après
quelques larmes de crocodile versées par
les uns et les autres notamment sur le
compte des élections régionales à peu de
frais parce que je vous rappelle quand
même si vous prenez l'ensemble des
présidents de région aujourd'hui si vous
calculez l'état exact de leur électorat
ils sont à moins de 10% des électeurs
ils sont présents de région avec moins
de 10% des électeurs dans la réalité ça
n'en fait pas moins des présidents de
région légitime
celle de la légitimité qu'est ce que
c'est une démocratie où mona d'ivoire a
rouvert avec des bourses de voix donc on
est parti de deux constats on a mené la
réflexion est parti de deux constats
déjà le premier constat c'est qu'il est
normal que les différentes les
différents courants d'idées politiques
se battent puisqu'on est en démocratie
pour gagner une élection ça c'est tout à
fait normal mais ce que je trouve
beaucoup moins normal en revanche c'est
qu'une fois qu'on a été lui qu'est ce
qui nous empêche de gouverner avec les
oppositions puisque finalement quand
vous êtes élu vous représentez rarement
plus de la moitié des français quelle
que soit quelle que soit l'élection
qu'est ce qui vous empêche derrière de
travailler en bonne intelligence avec
les oppositions pour les présidentielles
ça soit 20,2
il est le socle et cesser ceci dit au
général est entre 20 et 25% le socle du
premier tour pour les peaux pour les
prix de reconnaissance dans les grandes
caves et ça il y avait ce premier
constat est le deuxième constat on voit
la fracture totale avec les citoyens
entre les politiques et les citoyens de
deux choses l'une soit on sait pas
expliquer les choses il ya sûrement une
part de vérité là-dedans ça c'est vrai
on n'est pas très bon communicant faut
être fort et honnête là dessus soit on
reste sur des recettes éculées je pense
que c'est vrai aussi donc il ya un
moment il faut qu'on arrive à re pour
refaire contact avec les citoyens pour
expliquer que les politiques qui sont
mises en place qu'elles soient de droite
de gauche du centre peu importe il ya
des politiques qui sont efficaces etc
amène des résultats il faut amener la
preuve la preuve vraiment que ça se fait
et puis il ya l'autre partie je pense
qu'on n'a pas assez fait qu'ils étaient
pourtant au programme du président macro
mais pas que tous les présidents tous
les candidats pro médecin c'est la
partie ascendante c'est à dire écouter
ce qui se passe en bas pour essayer de
l'appliquer en os et produire des lois
qui ont une efficacité plus grande je
dis pas que les lois n'ont pas
d'efficacité mais leur application sur
le terrain est souvent compliqué
difficile et on travaille pas assez sur
l'évaluation de l'application et les
lois donc l'idée de confiance et de
m'aider à la fois des gens de la société
civile des élus de tous bords on est pas
on n'est pas là pour dire c'est
politique c'est pas le modèle
un jour l'air mon éthique elle bien sûr
je suis député et bien sûr les gens vont
faire l'amalgamme mais on enlève nos
étiquettes tout le monde est le bienvenu
tout le monde est le bienvenu dans
confluence et l'idée c'est qu'au travers
de réunions publiques on puisse dégager
des choses des idées peut-être simple
d'application que on ne voit pas
forcément quand on est en haut dans
notre tour d'ivoire de députés nationaux
ou même pire gouvernement et à l'elysée
et de remonter ça dans les ministères
ont été envoyés il ya quand même des
choses assez simples qu'on pourrait
faire et qui sont demandées par les gens
faisons-le et ça améliorera grandement
le quotidien et les gens et ils auront
une perception de l'application de la
politique au sens noble du terme celle
qui gère la cité d'accord celle qui fait
qui fait sens et qui rassemble on
pourrait le mettre en place là dessus je
vais vous prendre après je me tais
besoin je parle beaucoup je vais prendre
deux trois exemples qu'ils m'ont fait la
façon dont tous les uns les autres là je
n'accuse pas les citoyens plus que les
politiques on oublie les choses qui sont
faites sur des mesures très simples je
vous en prendre une très simple prenez
les femmes les familles monoparentales
des femmes seules avec des enfants et
qui ont des difficultés par exemple à
recouvrir enfin récupérer la pension
alimentaire je suis pas persuadé qu'ils
aient beaucoup de gens qui savent
aujourd'hui ou qui se souviennent
qu'aujourd'hui les femmes n'ont pas
besoin de d'attenté de procès à leur
mari pour récupérer la pension
alimentaire il suffit de vous adresser à
votre caisse d'allocations familiales
qui va prendre en charge la pension
alimentaire qui vaut qui va vous payer
la pension alimentaire et c'est l'état
qui se retournera or il se retourne tout
ce genre de mesure on a l'impression
qu'elle n'existe pas je prends un
dernier exemple la taxe d'habitation
peut discuter de la validité au pas de
sa suppression ça c'est autre chose mais
bon en tout cas on est parti pour
supprimer cette taxe d'habitation qui
était un impôt injuste puisque moi je me
vidais sky plus de taxe d'habitation que
quelqu'un à surface égale qui habite
dans le 7e arrondissement de paris avait
voilà c'est un peu c'est un peu bizarre
80% des français aujourd'hui de la paye
plus il ya eu un sondage qui a été fait
sur ces 80 % de français qui ne la paye
plus 70% d'entre eux ne se souviennent
pas l'avoir payée un jour pourtant ça
date pas d'il ya très longtemps ça
représente quand même un treizième mois
mais il ya plein de choses comme ça
mettre en place et puis reprendre des
idées moi j'ai beaucoup discuté des
entrepreneurs là depuis je suis revenu
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire au
niveau de la formation professionnelle
et de latin l'alternance on reste sur un
schéma qui est quand même assez anciens
il faut rénover tout ça il faut se
nourrir de ce qui se passe sur le
terrain et à linverse de dire aux gens
ce qu'il est possible de faire quand on
est politique ou élus que ce soit dans
une municipalité dans une interview au
département ou à la région ou même plus
haut donner aux gens les freins qui font
que des fois on fait pas forcément tout
ce qu'on peut faire parce que il ya nos
lois il ya notre constitution qui font
que on peut pas toujours faire tout donc
tel dialogue pour unique et l'action
refaire bien vous refaire le vert
une rupture
par exemple dont sur ce que vient de
dire bruno millièmes justement sur cette
coupure entre les entrées les français
la politique
en tant qu'élu local à quelque chose qui
peut me perturber c'est que quand on
parle de démocratie pour moi il ya
plusieurs échelons de démocratie les
corps intermédiaires et le sentiment que
je peux avoir moi aussi au sérieux en
tant que militant c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui en tant qu'élu sait aussi
que le gouvernement qu'on a aujourd'hui
un gouvernement qui est très très
descendants comme on l'a dit est avec
toi pas forcément beaucoup de respect
aussi pour les collectivités
territoriales
vous n'avez pas les taxes habitation
nous ce qu'on ressent dans les
collectivités c'est plein d'idées plein
dans le vide politique au plus près au
plus proche du terrain plus proche des
habitants et de leurs besoins et qu'on
est bloqués aussi pour des raisons des
raisons fiscales et on peut à la fois
sollicité que les gens payent moins
d'impôts mais à côté les collectivités
auront deux choix soit s'imposer
toujours plus d'austérité soit augmenter
les impôts l'imposition locale et donc
au final je suis pas sûr que les
français soient si gagnant que ça à
supprimer un impôt puisque derrière ça
veut dire moins de services publics ça
veut dire moins d'écoles potentiellement
moins de périscolaire - tout ce qu'on
peut tous que nous et sur le fond de la
suppression de la ccsa et c'est ce qui
est un problème est lié mine de rien
toutes ces mesures là elle touche au
plus proche des gens puisque finalement
c'est moi je suis persuadé que ce sont
les mairies qui donne les discours les
plus les plus réelles par rapport aux
gens ce que là c'est vrai une raison
l'état de la politique les maires sont
plutôt de plus apprécié que
les églises sont les derniers élus les
plus appréciés des fonderies et ça
commence à baisser si ça commence à
baisser et eliane il ya des rires des
agressions qu'on a vue physique
alors moi moi je vais pas revenir sur
l'histoire la taxe d'habitation journal
on n'a pas perdu des matchs à signaler
que c'est le premier gouvernement depuis
20 ans qui ne baissent pas les dotations
globales des collectivités puisque ce
que je sais ce qu'on vote à l'assemblée
nationale on n'a pas baissé alors quand
on parle de la dotation globale de
financement dès que des communes
effectivement en fonction de la
péréquation mais la péréquation c'est un
système peut-être qu'il va falloir
revoir là je suis d'accord avec vous
parce que la péréquation ne peut pas
bénéficier tout le temps qu à ceux qui
n'ont rien ou qui ont du mal il faut que
ceux qui n'ont rien et qui ont du mal et
essaye de faire en sorte d'aller mieux
parce qu'on n'a pas payé at vitam
aeternam pour ceux qui voient là parce
que ceux qui sont les plus vertueux
finalement voient leur dgf on appelle ça
la dgf baissé en revanche en revanche il
ya d'autres formes de financement dans
les communes je veux pas rentrer dans
les détails mais la d6 la ddtm qui qui
augmente aussi donc globalement les
finances des communes n'ont pas baissé
après c'est la répartition du
financement des communes selon les selon
les lignes qui a changé et sur la dgf
mais là je vous rejoins parce que moi je
suis dans une circonscription où sur la
dotation globale de financement de deux
des communes de ma circonscription tous
les ans avaient tous les ans sa baisse
et c'est la faute à la péréquation c'est
pas la faute est ce que votre
l'assemblée nationale en termes de
dotation et
je reviens à l'abstention rennes perd
brio
voilà bruno myle yen fait fait ce boulot
confluence vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes
pas abonné bien est ce que est ce que ça
vous intéresserait participer justement
à un bonbon qui se dit on va essayer de
convaincre les français de revenir voter
tout à fait moi je salue l'initiative de
bruno je trouve ça extrêmement
intéressant et j'y participerai
peut-être mais je voudrais revenir au
sujet est au coeur du sujet
l'abstention est en fait on fait le
constat quand même que si les gens ne
vont plus voter je pense qu'il ya deux
raisons essentielles en fait c'est
qu'ils ne comprennent plus les enjeux on
l'a vu beaucoup pour les les élections
intermédiaires notamment les régionales
et départementales
en fait ils n'ont plus de culture
du territoire et de culture politique
pour vraiment saisir les enjeux de ces
élections je pense que c'est la première
raison est la seconde raison c'est que
il ya
les gens aux besoins de vibrer pour la
politique c'est à dire ils ont besoin
d'une dynamique et c'est vrai qu'on voit
de plus en plus de campagnes qui qui qui
ne font plus vibrer vraiment les
citoyens et en fait l'humain est humain
et a besoin de vibrer pour des idées
pour une vraie vision de la france et
enfin catalogue un programme en
catalogne et je pense pour faire court
s'il y avait quatre pistes importantes
pour pour contrer un peu l'abstention
c'est la pédagogie de la politique donc
c'est et notamment à l'école
c'est-à-dire refaire une école citoyenne
parce qu'on constate que ceux qui n'ont
pas de culture politique du tout si on
n'a pas à l'école si les parents ne
sensibilisent pas les enfants à la
politique en fait il n'y a pas de
culture politique le
la deuxième point ce serait repenser
évidemment
l'organisation territoriale on a parlé
du millefeuille on a parlé de lui
parfois certains parlent du kouign amann
tellement il ya de couches donc je dis
gestes n'ont surtout pas le coup d'oeil
à man le troisième point je pense que
c'est redynamiser la vie politique c'est
à dire qu'on fonctionne sur les vieux de
vieilles recettes politique les meetings
les meetings plus personne ne va
uniquement les militants parce que il
n'ya pas de souffle il n'ya pas
d'oxygène il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas
de témoignages des gens de la société
sont de
donc voilà donc je pense que c'est le
troisième point est le quatrième point
c'est avoir des candidats qui ont une
vraie vision une vraie vision politique
c'est à dire et pas simplement ce que je
disais un catalogue avec une énumération
de un petit peu de toujours un petit peu
la même chose des candidats qui soit
proche des gens des candidats qui soit
claire qui soit pédagogique qui soit
engagé
enthousiaste et je pense que
voilà faut se réveiller et surtout des
candidats crédibles parce que ils feront
ce qu'il ce qu'ils ont dit voilà et donc
je pense que c'est un petit peu tout
c'est toutes ces pistes qui pourraient
redonner confiance en la en l'électorat
voilà je dis c'est vrai que
si on regarde qui s'abstient c'est en
effet plutôt
les gens qui disent qu'ils n'ont pas de
diplôme un terrain plutôt les jeunes
aussi d'ailleurs
sur ce discours de 2,2 bruno myle yen et
d'une paire brio votre réaction moi je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce que je
viens de dénoncer à nos pères brio mais
je voudrais revenir juste sur le thème
du débat au départ le bruno malienne du
par de l'abstention et l'expliquent que
les gens s'intéressent plus à la
politique et vaincus eux que et puis
tout d'un coup lui comme le représentant
du parti communiste oublie complètement
que l'abstention et des marais de joutes
politiques
le représentant du parti communiste nous
explique que le gouvernement est un
gouvernement qui ne devrait pas qui fait
pas les bonnes choses on a complètement
oublié et on comprend bien que les gens
peuvent pas s'intéresser à la politique
6 7 6 la politique c'est ça dès qu'on
parle de quelque chose c'est tout de
suite
il n'y a même pas eu de débat depuis
tout à l'heure on a dégagé le truc en
touche donc ça c'est extrêmement
troublant et puis enfin l'autre chose
c'est que quand bruno myle yens nous dit
les gens sont pas au courant de 2 des
histoires de prestations sociales et de
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
mais je veux dire on est dans une
démocratie il ya la presse m il ya la
télévision il y avait les jambes sont
cocasses qui n'ont pas envie d'être au
courant pas non plus les prendre par la
main je lui ai fait désolé si une femme
ne touche pas sa pension alimentaire et
qu'il n'est pas au courant que s'est
pris en main par la sécurité sociale je
suis désolé c'est totalement déprimant
même que si les gens se disent ah bon on
paie plus attaque celui des six rendent
pas compte j'ai des remises tant mieux
que ces gens là ne votent pas je dirais
c'est pas
je n'ai pas leur vote moi je
flâne ce mercredi
alors je pense qu'il ya deux
effectivement de deux problématiques la
première problématique c'est
le désintérêt des français pour
la politique et pas aussi dans une
période un peu particulière de la crise
sanitaire
pendant la pandémie je suis pas certain
enfin on n'a parlé que du côté de 19
quel que soit le parti politique
et puis il n'y a pas eu de débat
politique du tout pendant fin pas du
tout très peu de débat politique ces
campagnes pendant pendant un an et demi
pour le report des élections régionales
et ce lorsque je pense qu'en termes de
compréhension on n'a rien on a quelque
part mal joué mais un père brio le
rappelait d'ailleurs moi je pense qu'ils
ont été plus intéressant tout en
respectant justement le tempo
démocratique de faire les
départementales au mois de juin parce
qu'on avait déjà dépassé de deux mois
l'échéance des élections et de reporter
les de reporter des régionales un début
y aurait la différence entre moi j'ai vu
sur les bureaux de vote les gens
comprenaient pas qu'ils habitent deux
fois deux fois il y en a qui arrivent
bien dit mais pourquoi deux fois
comprenez pas la différence entre les
départementales des régionales
la répartition des prérogatives entre
les deux est d'ailleurs un peu compliqué
de comprendre la répartition des
prérogatives parce qu'il y en a qui
doivent se marcher sur les pieds aussi
entre les départementales et régionales
ont donc extrait beaucoup plus donc je
pense que pendant un an et demi les gens
ont un peu décrochées se retrouver
enfermé sans même un mouvement
existe et finaliste poursuit quoi voilà
qui mirent caractéristiques de ces
élections alors est ce que c est ce que
c'est un mouvement quand on voit des
gens qui descendent dans la rue pour
manifester c'est pas un mouvement c'est
plusieurs mouvements c'est alors la
lucarne à tout à l'heure parce qu'ils
sont trop jeunes c'est complètement
l'hétéroclite fédéraux clip
et puis l'autre les matic effectivement
c'est assez le sens de la démocratie
pour les citoyens parce que ne pas aller
voter c'est quand même relativement fin
ça me paraît relativement enfin tout ça
me paraît grave dans une démocratie que
de ne pas comprendre quel est l'intérêt
du vote et c'est vrai que c'est facile
de ne pas aller voter pour ensuite
critiqué a critiqué aussi voir son cas
leader qui n'est plus franchement oui ça
c'est ça pourrait moderniser sa aussi à
moderniser la façon de voyager mais que
se crisper sur le fait qu'il faut
absolument aller dans un bureau de vote
tel d'immenses et un pantalon là aussi
on pourrait on pourrait peut-être
changer jo et je voudrais alors vous
nous expliquer les uns et les autres en
dehors même des convictions politiques
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à vous
engager
allez-y ben moi je pense que je pense
que c'est les valeurs et je pense que
beaucoup de jeunes quand on parle d'
attention c'est le s'étoffer domaines
notamment de jeunes d'électeurs qui ne
seront pas vos copains quoi après ça que
moi et moi j'aime l'histoire donc moi
j'ai eu un regard historique sur tout ce
qui avait été fait en france et sur
l'histoire des partis politiques tout ce
qu'ils avaient fait des élus depuis en
gros 45 on pouvait dire même un petit
peu avant donc c'est l'attachement à des
valeurs particulières on pourrait dire
aussi des choses qui nous gêne dans la
société donc on a envie de changer donc
c'est pour ça qu'on s'engage je pense
après moi j'ai faut quand même aussi
voir une chose je pense qu'on est aussi
autour de la table des gens qui vivent
plutôt bien moi je pense à beaucoup de
camarades aussi qui qui vont avoir des
travaux précaires qui vont avoir qui
n'ont pas avoir un contrat de travail
qui va leur permettre de bien pouvoir
vivre des gens aussi qui on parle du
travail dans le travail et aussi la
question de la gouvernance dans le
travail puisque comment on peu comment
faire comprendre aux gens qu'ils ont
droit de parler quand ils sont en dehors
de l'entreprise
et quand ils ont de l'entreprise n'ont
plus droit de parler et doit respecter
la hiérarchie très dur moi je pense que
si on démocratise on parlait de
démocratie dans l'école par exemple si
on rajoute de la démocratie dans les
entreprises par exemple que les gens ils
se rendent compte que ce de ce que c'est
de d'avoir du pouvoir sur toute leur vie
à la fois la vie citoyenne vie sociale
vie sociale dans le sens gouvernance de
l'entreprise pour moi il y aura il y
aurait un progrès là-dessus et on le
voit très bien c'est défendre première
votre engagement au c ur si je devais
résumer ça sape tout le souci de l'autre
des soucis de la vie collective quoi oui
c'est peut-être que toutes les villes
toutes les vies sont dignes on lui doit
aussi a de la valeur et moi je pense à
toutes ces personnes qui subissent
beaucoup leur vie mon but aussi celles à
travers la politique leur permettre d'un
saut tonomy de s'émanciper sont
possibles vandry des capelles
je pense que le constat on l'a tous fait
c'est que les abstentionnistes sont le
plus grand parti de france où on a
besoin et à partie et j'ai fini 15e pas
partie est bon les français ne se
reconnaissent plus dans la politique et
ne se reconnaissent plus et ne sont pas
satisfaits de l'offre politique
aujourd'hui
attendez
comment on peut dire ça parce que quand
vous regardez qui se présente à une
élection pour éditique et enfin ça va de
l'extrême gauche à l'extrême droite en
passant par les parties de rationnel le
sens de ce terme on peut pas dire que
l'homme politique n existe pas mais les
jeunes en tout cas quand je moi je
discute souvent avec des jeunes en
rentrant de soirée etc une disqueuse et
ben aujourd'hui ils ont ils vont pas ils
vont pas se déplacer dans les yeux pour
élire quelqu'un qui fera pas ce dont ce
dont pourquoi ils ont voté aujourd'hui
quand on arrive au pouvoir souvent le
programme e on ne le fait pas ah oui non
c'est ça c'est autre chose c'est
peut-être une défiance à leur vis-à-vis
des élus mais sachant que l'oeuvre est
très pâle je crois pas à une offre
politique on peut pas dire qu'elle est
je suis alors je vais dire franchement
je ne veux pas je jeu pas encore donné
de de l'eau au moulin de jean charles
lajoie nîmes et je vous écoute tous les
deux et c'est très bien vous avez un
engagement fort et moi je les connais
aussi je vais en étonner certains quand
j'avais 18 ans je te parti communiste
met donc
voilà comme quoi bon j'en ai beaucoup
plus jeune et marie mai mais quand je
vous écoute tous les deux vous avez des
discours et c'est un peu ce qui
m'effraie mais c'est ça vous avez des
discours très militant très politique et
très axée uniquement sur votre vision de
la société
votre vision politique j'entends pas
votre vision globale et vous non globez
pas l'ensemble de la société et
finalement je pense que ces discours là
aujourd'hui c'est mon avis hein ces
discours là aujourd'hui n'intéresse pas
forcément la majorité des gens c'est ça
que je veux dire vous parlez à vos
électeurs à ce niveau à ceux qui pensent
la même chose que vous mais vous n'en
globez pas le reste de la population
mais je pense que la politique se meurt
de sa une idée n est pas bonne parce
qu'elle est de droite ou de gauche une
idée elle est bonne parce qu'elle est
bonne tout simplement c'est ça rien
d'autre elle peut venir du parti
communiste elle peut même venir de chez
eric zemmour on verra sur le long terme
mais moi c'est ma conviction profonde et
tant qu'on n'arrivera pas effectivement
à trier faire le tri entre ce qui est de
l'idéologie pure que chacun en soit moi
j'ai pas la mamie de logique vous ni que
vous mais mon idéologie quand elles ne
dépassent pas les frontières de mon
électorat je la développe pas forcément
ou en tout cas j'essaye de l'adapter à
l'ensemble des citoyens pour faire union
faire faire majorité en tous cas dans
l'acceptation et quand je vous ai que
tous les deux je suis un peu je vous le
dis franchement je ne sais pas méchant
je suis un peu étonné de ce discours là
et en même temps je le comprends parce
que si on n'a pas ces discours là à
l'âge que vous avez on les a jamais mais
bon voilà c'est le petit point que je
voulais réussir à les utiliser
moi je pense que justement il faut
assumer le clivage dont le débat en a
plein d intérêt je prends ma jeunesse ma
délégation au niveau municipal sur le
logement social quand on a un terrain et
qu'on veut choisir qui sont à construire
est ce qu on fait plutôt du privé dans
ce cas sa peine la population qui ont
fait du social à qui on répond à quel
intérêt on répond moi je pense que quand
on est quand on est élu notamment et je
vous le dit dossier sur votre site de
député vous défendez les intérêts de vos
électeurs on a compté font tous des
intérêts différents il ya des intérêts
divergents et sur des décisions n'est
pas de bonne solution il ya des
solutions avec des avis divergents des
intérêts divers besoins avec les décaler
vers les personnes sanna persson de
l'homme et mes conseils moi j'aime pas
trop l'idée de bonne idée parce que
avril des idées qui font l'accord
consensus pour tout le monde on est
d'accord mais des idées qui sont
clientes et des idées ou forcément il va
y avoir je veux parler de démocratie
dans le travail pour moi moi je trouve
ça moi j'ai pas envie de trahir nos
entreprises où ma voix ne compte pas ce
que je suis je suis citoyen et j'ai
envie d'un citoyen sur tous les aspects
de ma vie et ça évidemment je rentre en
contradiction avec les propriétaires
lucratif de mon entreprise et ça c'est
un débat qui est qui continuera il y
aura pas de bonne solution qui mettra
tout le monde d'accord
j'ai eu des mots avec félix je crois que
c'est vous qui parlez des corps
intermédiaires oui
du coup comment vous expliquer s'il y a
parce que vous êtes un peu généralistes
sur le fait que les salariés se sentent
mal dans leur entreprise ils n'ont pas
de voix comment vous expliquez que dans
le privé qu'il n'y a que 6 % de
représentativité au niveau syndical
parce que c'est la voix des salariés les
syndicats donc albi à un problème là
aussi ces décrets sur deux deux
solutions la première c'est le fait que
les syndicats n'ont pas de pouvoir dans
l'entreprise ou à part juste
propositions non ça c'est pas mais donc
voilà je fais pas dans la gouvernance
d'entreprise évidemment ils sont tous
d'accord qu ils sont consultés sur
beaucoup de décisions mais sur la
gouvernance des objectifs la
planification d'entreprise ils ne sont
pas consultés et donc à pouvoir
d'opposition et malheureusement on est
obligés de faire grève pour essayer
d'imposer sa voix parce qu'on n'est pas
on aime on n'est pas dans un capitalisme
rhénan par exemple où on aurait déjà un
tiers pour les salariés c'est plus
compliqué c'est pas un season ise en
france est le deuxième grand pointe pour
moi bah c'est aussi la peur c'est que
dans beaucoup d'entreprises quand on a
un contrat qui ne permet pas de pouvoir
pleinement s'engager de façon
syndicalement enfin avoir l'étiquette
cgt c'est pas simple dans toute
l'entreprise ça peut bloquer la carrière
et tout le monde n'est pas prêt à
accepter surtout dans un système
universaliste donc ça veut dire que les
victoires de la minorité syndicale
appartient à tous ceux à qui on n'est
pas comme en belgique ou pour avoir pour
avoir une si côté social et bien il faut
adhérer à enfin dans sa vie où les
syndicats sont forts mais au
final
on a laissé des pays où il ya celle
cassant y en avoir est étudiée à adhérer
au syndicat chez nous y'a pas y'a pas
intérêt on peut que félix de tours oui
mais pour revenir sur la crise de la
démocratie et et l'abstention je dirais
que je vais rejoindre à la fois année
bruno mais peut-être revenir sur un
point et on voit en quand mes camarades
on va dire jeunes engagés débattre c'est
qu'on confond peut-être le politique
celui qui s'engage qui dépend des idées
et qu'il allait les mettre sur le
terrain qu'ils soient simples militants
ou élus et la politique et je pense que
les gens ont à la fois un problème avec
le politique l'élu ou langages et qui ne
défend que ses idées et qui va parfois
essayé m en voulant les communiqués de
les imposer et la politique qui pour moi
en tout cas chez les jeunes va souffrir
de 2,3 problème et on est revenu je vais
aller très vite mais un point un rapport
au temps dans la dent dans ma génération
dans les moins de 30 ans qui s'est
accéléré et donc une difficulté à se
poser et à revenir sur le temps long à
regarder ce qui a été fait par les
partis ce qui pourrait être fait et à
prendre un peu de recul un problème de
confiance ça a été dit il ya il ya il ya
une défiance envers le politique
puisqu'il y a des il ya beaucoup
d'exemples de gens qui se font élire et
qu'ils ne font pas forcément ce pourquoi
ils ont été élus et puis il ya un
problème de rapport à l'information je
pense qui va avec la la temporalité de
notre époque c'est qu'on a énormément
d'informations très rapidement mais on
va forcément le temps un de le vérifier
de le confronter et ensuite d'aller
d'aller l'expliquer c'est peut-être la
différence entre faire preuve de deux
communes fin de ces la différence pour
communiquer et faire de la pédagogie la
une des premières solutions je pense
pour ramener les gens aux urnes c'est
être pédagogue plus que de vouloir
absolument comme disait un communiqué
dans des catalogues sur les prochaines
mesures à mettre en place alors va poser
la question abstention faut-il se
résigner
[Musique]
alors oui non ou alors on peut répondre
non évidemment ça bête de se résigner
mais en même temps est-ce qu'on n'est
pas dans un mouvement qui est un peu
semblable à celui des états-unis de
d'autres démocraties ou aux faux bas
même dans les grandes élections il ya
moins de 50% des électeurs qui se
déplacent mais faut pas faut absolument
pas se résignant ça à cela parce que si
vous vous résignez cela quelles que
soient nos idées c'est fini il ya plus
de démocratie et démocratie n'existe
plus en tout cas pas au sens grec du
terme est telle qu'on la connaît alors
on peut on peut rêver d'autres
démocraties qui serait plus directive
parce qu'on nous parle de démocratie
populaire autres on voit bien dans les
différents pays ce que ça donne c'est
des choses un petit peu plus autoritaire
qui vous permettent d'ailleurs de passer
des mesures qui sont pas forcément
sympathique très bien et peut-être aussi
sur ces pays-là faire avancer les choses
je pense notamment à la chine qui fait
débat qui fait des mesures en ce moment
notamment sur les sur les géants de
l'internet qui sont radicales peut-être
peut-être ont-ils raison de le faire
d'ailleurs mais la façon dont ils le
font maïak en chine qu'on peut faire
comme ça
c'est efficace j'avais dit qu'en termes
d'écologie le jour où la chine
s'éveillera en cinq ans et quittera tout
le monde parce que tout le monde
marchera à pied et on arrêtera tout bon
voilà mais on n'est pas dans ce genre de
régime c'est pas notre culture c'est pas
notre histoire c'est pas notre histoire
donc il faut pas se résigner fonction
pas se résigner moi ma vie politique on
va dire qu'elle est plutôt derrière moi
que devant moi si je fais encore cinq
six ou sept ans de politique ça sera le
maximum j'aimerais employés ce temps là
justement à réconcilier les gens avec
l'action politique à faire en sorte que
les gens se réapproprient la politique
et s'intéresse à nouveau à la politique
et et s'informe de la bonne manière je
vous prends juste un exemple parmi tout
ce qu'on peut voir sur la toile on a
tous des gens sur saône sur nos réseaux
sociaux qui sont plus ou moins
complotistes et j'ai vu dernièrement la
sté ce week-end à qui disait d'ailleurs
c'est quoi cette histoire de haut
commissariat au plan ils font rien et
que c'est un alors ces gens là qui passe
un temps fou à les chercher des fêtes
news enfin qui sont abreuvés de fait
nous parce que les algorithmes font que
ne trouve même pas les 30 secondes
nécessaires pour aller sur le site du
haut commissariat au plan et voir que le
commissariat au plan
produit des notes assez régulièrement en
moyenne tous les deux mois la dernière
date 2 juillet elle est sur
l'agriculture et le haut commissariat au
plan et les faits pour essayer
d'imaginer à 30 ans et moi j'ai vu la
dernière fois c'était l'agriculture donc
ça m'intéressait au premier chef et je
trouve que la note est très bien fait
bien évidemment il travaille voilà donc
il faut on a on a malheureusement depuis
les années 60 de plus en plus de temps
de cerveau disponible
qu'on utilise je pense pas bien parce
que les réseaux sociaux ont fait que les
algorithmes effectivement quand vous
avez un centre d'intérêt les algorithmes
vous renvoie toujours sur vos centres
d'intérêts sans vous éclairer sur les
autres centres d'intérêt que vous
pourriez découvrir et on utilise mal
notre temps de cerveau discours tous
mois avant de faire avant d'être avant
d'être député je me je n'analyse est pas
les choses comme je les analyse
aujourd'hui j'étais pris aussi dans la
nasse voilà
on dire sur ce que vous disiez sur la
chine et les géants d'internet je pense
que aussi
les citoyens se disent que de toute
façon les politiques peuvent pas faire
grand chose face au monde financier et
au monde de ces géants qui finalement
voilée rouillen tellement quand même
verrou il est politique complètement
vrai parce qu'il vous aura pas échappé
qui s'est passé ou non mais vous
rappelle qu'il ya eu un événement
considérable que la bo quasi totalité
des pays de l'om c est signé justement
cette imposition dégâts femmes à 15%
rien qu'un sport c'est pas ça c'est pas
ça que jour principe ce que je mets en
avant c'est que la quasi totalité ont
signé c'était impensable il ya deux
trois ans ça pèse quand même c'est vrai
que les c'est vrai que s'affirme aussi
semblablement le sentiment dans
l'opinion que le plat politique ne plus
pouvoir - la fois qu'on avait et elle a
probablement moins le radier pour
beaucoup et l'europe oui parce que
l'europe a été naïve trop longtemps elle
en train de personnes à éviter on va
voir ce que ça va être
un mot de pardon une paire brio sur la
résignation pas de résiliation
surtout pas se résigner et non non non
non c'est un enjeu évidemment
fondamental
un politique et et des libertés donc non
non non non surtout pas se résigner et
je pense que c'est vraiment aux
candidats
de prouver désormais on disait avec
jean-charles tout à l'heure que l'été
était vraiment ça le matin parce qu'il
nous permettait d'aller dans les
provinces nous qui sommes franciliens
et de discuter avec les gens mais soyons
soyons vraiment simple les gens ce
qu'ils veulent c'est que quand un
politique s'engage il fasse ce qu'il a
dit ce pour quoi il s'est engagé et puis
deuxièmement je pense que il a besoin de
sentir de s'identifier un peu aux
politiques et de sentir que ce politique
comprend ces problèmes et proche de lui
et se mettre à sa place et sera résoudre
ces problèmes du quotidien voilà moi je
pense que non et c'est tout à fait
et c'est tout à fait jouable voilà il
faut que les candidats qui partent sur
ces élections
évidemment déterminante pour notre pays
soit dans sedan dans ce formatage là et
pas dans le formatage parisien de
l'entretoit et de dire écoute on a
promis ça mais on fera pas grave comme
aux enfants dès ce matin
j'entendais ce matin la radio
tel budget ça y est c'est c'est bon tel
budget engagé ça y est c'est engagé mais
s'est engagée pour faire quoi de quoi
etc c'est il suffit pas de deux
de dépenser l'argent public pour pour
prouver que on a on a rempli sa mission
non qu'est ce qu'on a fait qu'est-ce que
le
la communication aussi à son rôle le
contrôler le suivi d'un programme une
vraie vision politique moi je pense que
si si on repart sur c'est vraiment c'est
basique de la politique je pense que les
français sauront tout à fait prêt à
retourner aux urnes
sur ses basiques avec peut-être une
modernisation en effet des procédures de
vote en effet peut-être de la démocratie
c'est vrai que
les réseaux sociaux aussi nombreux pour
être aussi mieux utiliser ou bien
utilisé et avec une démocratie peut être
un peu plus direct c'est une vraie
question qu'on pourrait poser mais je
voudrais qu'on aborde le deuxième thème
la présidentielle il ya des sondages
intéressants qui sont tombés ce we can
et c'était je crois franz olivier
giesbert dans le point qui était très
son papier présidentielle la droite
peut-elle encore perdre 2022
[Musique]
alors il ya deux sondages qui sont
parues ce matin dans le parisien ce
retard dans le figaro qui montre ce qui
n'était pas vrai dans l'est dans les
derniers mois que si le vote avait lieu
aujourd'hui évidemment emmanuel macron
serait en tête dès le premier tour assez
largement devant marine le pen très
largement devant les candidats de droite
la gauche
allait diviser votre candidat fait à peu
près 2 3% par le crédit de 3 % il ya
mélenchon il y aura peut-être montebourg
il ya un écologiste il y aura peut-être
madame hidalgo donc la gauche est très
divisée a priori donc ne jouera pas pour
la présidentielle comment comment vous
expliquer justement ce regain si je peux
dire que des manuels macron
je pense que est ce que est ce qu'il
n'ya pas de l'idée au fond que de se
dire bon il ya bush président américain
n 1 qui feraient mieux de penser à deux
sujets d'abord je pense que les français
ont quand même la perception que malgré
ce ce mandat excessivement difficile ou
même le dire entre la crise des gilet
jaune
la réforme des retraites et la crise
sanitaire le président a tenu le cap et
il a tenu le cap sur les formes les
réformes qu'il avait proposé puisque
même ses opposants reconnaissent à dire
dans les coulisses que oui il a à peu
près rempli 80% des projets qu'il avait
présentées je sais pas si les français
on réellement conscience de ça mais bon
ça c'est un fait que beaucoup du rabbin
il a rien fait c'est pas vrai pour le
coup c'est pas vrai si on n'y aurait
jamais eu autant de gens dans la rue
enfin je souffre irakien aurait eu plus
à ce moment là mais bon passons il ya ça
d'une part et d'autre part mais on en
vient au début de la discussion les
propositions qui sont faites à droite
comme à gauche aujourd'hui des
hâtif candidats n'enchante personne ou
vraie personne n'a l'air vraiment dit se
dire untel ou untel oui oh là là
fantastique est-ce que ça va être
l'homme ou la femme providentiel je
trouve que les partis politiques dans
leur ensemble ont cette espèce d'un
capacité à se renouveler ou à renouveler
leurs idées qui font qu'ils restent
toujours sur les mêmes thématiques si je
prends la thématique des salariés dans
l'entreprise par exemple je peux vous
donner raison sur un certain nombre de
points sans aucun problème mais vous ne
pouvez pas systématiquement depuis plus
d'un siècle dire les salariés sont les
gentils et les patrons sont les méchants
voyez ce que je veux dire dans la
rhétorique si vous l'avez dit à un
moment nous l'avait dit les
propriétaires lucratif 7 et votre terme
les propriétaires lucratif je suis
désolé de vous apprendre c'est une base
une entreprise est là pour gagner de
l'argent je suis désolé de vous
apprendre aussi que pendant la crise ya
des entreprises qui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent qui n'ont pas donné d'argent
alors à ses actionnaires ça existe j'en
connais mais qui ont maintenu
l'intéressement et la participation pour
les salariés je ne pense pas que dans ce
genre d'entreprise les salariés soient
mieux traitées qu'ailleurs 6 alors d'un
côté pécunier peut-être oui mais
simplement vous voyez on ne peut pas
faire de généralités comme vous le
faites et tous les discours que
j'entends qu'ils sont bloqués dans une
idéologie mois me paraissent 20 ils me
paraissent mme pas intéresser les gens
si on est tout à fait honnête gouverner
un pays gouverné une commune gouverner
une intercommunalité une région un
département si les politiques étaient
tout à fait honnête il ya 80% des
décisions vous prenez qui sont qui
viennent de la réalité même du terrain
de la réalité même de la situation c'est
d'édition vous prenez pas ce qu'on
n'avait pas le choix de faire autrement
parce que la situation vous l'imposent
ça laisse finalement très petite part à
l'idéologie que vous allez saupoudrer
sur les différents textes pour le pour
le gouvernement par exemple vous allez
cheveux poudrés sur les différents
textes vous présenter à l'assemblée
nationale mais c'est pas l'idéologie qui
fait le gouvernement se bat pays c'est
la réalité du pays dans une campagne
assez idéologie voilà donc un père
brillant justement il ya c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup d'études qui disent la
droite est majoritaire en france on y
reviendra parce que c'est peut-être
c'est peut-être une vision un peu fausse
mais bon
c'est vrai qu'aucun quand ils vous
soutenez plus tôt valérie pécresse mais
on voit bien qu'aucun candidat de droite
qui se détache quoi décret c'est
bertrand sont au coude à coude y en a
pas un qui s'impose en tout cas
alors deux petites choses alors d'abord
pour faire le lien avec le premier sujet
quand vous dites patrice les sondages
disent que ça c'est aussi un facteur
d'abstention parce qu'à force de dire
les sondages disent que en fait les
français pensent que tout est joué et
donc puisque les sondages disent que
c'est pas la peine qu'on se déplace
voilà donc ça c'était une première
petite remarque
sur la candidature donc effectivement je
vais pas être très objective puisque je
soutiens avec beaucoup de conviction la
candidature de valérie pécresse parce
que justement je trouve
alors bon il n'y a jamais de 2 je veux
dire d'idées fracassant puisqu'on
travaille sur le quotidien des français
sur l'avenir de la france et c'est donc
on retombe forcément sur les sujets
structurants d'une part le régalien
d'autre part le libéral je trouve que
valérie pécresse justement
et et se distingue dans son programme
par son côté
droite très régaliennes elle revient sur
des lignes force
sur
l'immigration en osant dire les choses
sur la sécurité en osant dire les choses
sur la justice donc où elle est très
très claire et elle est donc elle a ce
côté très libérale très innovant sur
l'entreprise sur
l'écologie avec un axe justement
l'écologie du quotidien c'est à dire que
les gens puissent se projeter
dans une écologie qui leur semblent pas
quelque chose d'éternel mans
inaccessible aujourd'hui on doit être
dans le pragmatique de l'écologie prend
pas vraiment
si si quand on voit très concrètement à
la région tout ce qui a été entrepris
d'un point de vue écologique
toutes les mesures qui ont été
entreprises et budget qui a été consacré
on se dit que c'est assez prometteur
pour la france
jean charles denis alors de juste deux
choses pour paraphraser
la première suis tout à fait d'accord
sur les sondages c'est vrai que on
absolument l'impression quand des
sondages a répliqué que les produits
sont sains c'est celle là c'est une
image à un moment donné en effet bien
sûr mais on peut tout à fait comprendre
que les gens se disent bon bah à quoi
bon ces jouets c'est comme ça ça va donc
ça c'est la première la deuxième chose
c'est bruno milian disait oui y'a rien
d'enthousiasmant mais moi je ne demande
pas on nous propose une révolution je
veux dire il faut reconnaître aussi une
chose c'est que en france pour 95% des
gens la france est une sorte de paradis
ils se croient peut-être en enfer mais
pour 95% des gens ça va donc ya pas non
plus les gens ils n'ont pas envie de 2,2
lendemain
révolutionnaire de catastrophe deux
projets complètement il faut ce que les
gens veulent c'est que la france soit
gérée elle n'est pas si mal géré que ça
et voilà il n'y a pas de dans les
principaux quoi
emmanuel macron fait plutôt bien le job
après on peut critiquer certaines choses
mais ça n'a rien de catastrophique
valérie pécresse et les propositions qui
sont un petit peu différente sur eux et
qu'ils se trouvent assez séduisant sur
le problème de l'immigration de
l'islamisme et sur la sécurité c'est en
gros ce qui la différencie je pense mais
anne perrot peut-être me contredire de
d'emmanuel mâcon et c'est aussi pour ça
que il n'y a pas beaucoup de death passe
pour cette droite là parce que les
différences sont minimes avec le
président m'a conquis rsa président de
centre-droit donc centré tout
centre-droit donc c'est vrai que pour la
droite ça va être très con c'est très
compliqué
cette question au plus mais bien
évidemment valérie pécresse ce pourrait
être un autre très bonne première
ministre de de macron
je pense que c'est un peu tout peut-être
pour lui dire ça mais on ne sait jamais
il pourrait d'ailleurs y avoir une
cohabitation entre les élections
législatives
oui mais c'était huit mois c'est un nom
qui n'engagent qu'elle au moment où elle
le dit
félix del tôt est ce que justement c'est
pas cette question à laquelle répondent
les français est ce que quelqu'un
d'autre ferait mieux que celui qui est
en place sauf jeu aaa date et heure avec
les programmes que l'on connaît des
candidats déclarés ou ou auprès déclaré
on peut pas dire que quelqu'un me ferait
mieux si on prend l'exemple de valérie
pécresse l angle peut-être un peu plus
sur son sur son aile droite étant donné
que la le gouvernement actuel et de
centres de centres centre-droit est elle
a peut-être plus de propositions sur
l'immigration et la sécurité mais encore
une fois je pense que c'est un problème
de lisibilité en convoi le nombre de
candidats qui sont déclarés en fait
l'espace au centre il est il est
gigantesque sans vouloir l' exagérer en
fait il ya personne au centre si ce
n'est à l'heure actuelle
la candidature d'emmanuel macron alors
qu'à gauche on a une multiplicité de
candidats qui ont chacun une une forme
de radicalité si vous me permettez le
terme que ce soit sur le rapport au
travail sur le rapport au capitalisme
sur le rapport à l'écologie et à droite
on a une multiplicité de candidat qui
arrive qui pour certains n'ont pas de
radicalité je ne dis pas que la
candidature de xavier bertrand ou
valérie pécresse porterait une forme de
radicalité mais on sent quand même une
tendance à venir chercher un électorat
de droite et est encore en cours dans un
instant mais voilà le fait on est avec
nous à un jeune et l'eire qui soit
génération z c'est aussi significative
dans une partie du d'un mouvement les
républicains qui s'est décalé à droite
en pensant exister face à emmanuel
macron en allant du côté de marine le
pen est en fait on le voit dans les
sondages ça ça consolide une centralité
quand même autour de la figure d'
emmanuel macron et ça dessert à la fois
marine le pen qui diminuerait un peu
dans les sondages pour voir un candidat
de droite qui n'explose ray par encore
un qui n'exposent pas pour le moment et
qui n'explosera peut-être pas et un eric
zemmour qui ferait un score
pas si mal que ça pour un candidat qui
se déclarerait ont eu droit avant
l'heure mais qui mais qui encore une
fois serait en fait un des résidus à la
fois de républicains et de rassemblement
national ils n'iraient pas forcément
chercher un un électorat différents et
peut-être pour reprendre une phrase et
et c'est peut-être qu'on pourrait
recommander à au parti des républicains
pour cette élection à la droite jean
françois copé disait que dans son parti
les primaires étaient une machine à
perdre on l'a vu en 2017 est ce que ce
sont là des primaires dans un instant
mais pardon et je voudrais alors revenir
sur un point sur lequel à mon avis enfin
un contresens pg je vais interroger bono
médiane là dessus on entend beaucoup
dire au fond macro c'est un candidat de
droite est-ce que c'est pas une erreur
de dire ça est ce que justement n'est
pas au top parce que les gens lui ça va
encore gré de ce qu'il a fait il ya cinq
ans c'est à dire faire exploser
justement cette france coupée en deux
cette coupure entre la droite et la
gauche suivant moi j'ai augmentons
centriste extrémistes comme dit à
l'oreille je suis incapable de vous dire
c'est un candidat de droite ont un
candidat de gauche il ya des mesures
sociales qui ont été prises bien que
tout le monde l'est ni il faudra qu'on a
en face le listing il ya eu énormément
de mesures de gauche qui ont été prises
de mesures sociales qui ont été prises
que n'ont pas fait les précédents
gouvernements et on peut remonter dans
le temps très loin avant de trouver
autant de mesures sociales faites sur
sur un quinquennat n'oublions pas que
nous sommes sur un quinquennat dans le
temps jadis il y avait le septennat qui
vous permettait d'agir sur la plus
longue durée donc déjà c'est pour moi
c'est une fausse dénomination
effectivement ce qu'on retient c'est que
emmanuel macron à libérer l'économie et
même macron a fait effectivement
énormément ce que les gens appellent des
cadeaux aux entrepreneurs il a
simplement mis les entreprises
françaises au même niveau d'imposition
enfin il essaye de le mettre le même
niveau d'imposition moyen que celui qui
existe en europe pour rendre les
entreprises compétitives par rapport à
leurs concurrents ne serait-ce qu
européen et puis après mondiaux on voit
que ça commence à porter ses fruits
puisque je crois je me trompe peut-être
mais je ne crois pas la france est
devenue le premier pays en termes
d'investissements entreprenariale
d'europe ce qui n'était pas le cas avant
la crise que vides nous apprend aussi
énormément de choses la crise la crise
qu duc vinh nous avons énormément de
choses toutes ces délocalisations qu'on
avait acté les uns derrière les autres
la droite comme la gauche et je ne
conteste pas qu'il l'ait fait parce que
au moment où ils ont pris leur décision
peut-être qu'effectivement c'était la
solution économique la meilleure à
prendre aujourd'hui on revient et on va
faire de la réindustrialisation
c'est pas seulement emmanuel macron
j'imagine que tous les candidats plus ou
moins libéraux porte la même chose donc
ça c'est ce que je vous disais dans la
situation la situation vous impose
souvent la politique que vous allez
développer et puis la plus grande mesure
sociale qu'on ait connu semaine à mâcon
donc excusez-moi président des riches
c'est quand même la survie de toute
l'économie française et de tous les
salariés pendant 18 mois de crise enfin
le chômage partiel assurer à tous
pendant 18 mois de crise ça veut dire
que les français on rêve grâce monde a
les écrans oui mais les français ont
touché en est ce qu'il gagnait 15 ans ce
qui entraîne sensation d'une oasis
aujourd'hui c'est une vraie mesure
sociale c'est ce qui nous permet de
repartir aujourd'hui peut-être un petit
peu plus fort que les autres voilà et
puis après la dette ça encore je vous
renvoie sur le haut commissariat au plan
café note la dette pour l'instant les
cantonais et effectivement quand la
croissance reprendra il faudra commencer
à rembourser petit à petit une reste
plus beaucoup de temps je voudrais qu'on
parle des primaires
à un brio vous vous êtes favorable des
prix mais repos pour dégager un candidat
de droite mais bertrand veut pas y aller
donc bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr c'est la
condition
absolue pour qu'il n'y ait qu'un
candidat de droite
et que la candidature de droite qui a
vraiment toute sa légitimité et est une
vraie farce dans le prochain scrutin
bien sûr de kerpel pourquoi alors vous
êtes génération z pourquoi zemmour doit
y aller déjà parce qu'il a attendu par
de nombreux français on sait il est
demandé par les jeunes mais pas
forcément parce que par les jeunes il a
attendu par les jeunes sur les réseaux
sociaux et sur le terrain on s'est
réveillé la france s'est réveillée en
juin avec dix mille affiches les émaux
président dans toute la france
sur les réseaux sociaux
eric zemmour est souvent en tendances
sur twitter donc oui il est demandé et
il est demandé par un électorat bon qui
est certains portent à part la division
de la droite pardon hein mais exige de
faire perdre la droite parce que s'il y
va pour l'hexagone va pas faire perdre
la droite l eczéma va faire gagner la
droite parce que c'est le meilleur
candidat qui puisse c'est qu'ils
puissent qu'ils puissent remporter ces
élections présidentielles d autres
points en moyenne derrière les avis et
bertrand que d'ici à avril il va passer
devant et non seulement ça il va passer
la barre des 20% mais je suis persuadé
d'accord d'accord ben on se retrouvera
moi j'ai un petit problème même si si si
je peux me permettre je vais te tutoyer
parce qu'on se connaît bien j'ai un
petit problème sur la primaire sur la
primaire à droite c'est que j'ai si j'ai
bien tout compris
christian jacob a demandé à ses troupes
il est dans une position inconfortable
allocution jacques aubert voilà de dire
bon voilà on va faire la primaire il y
en a un qui gagnera mais si celui qui
gagne est derrière xavier bertrand il
faudra qu'ils s'effacent au profit
xavier bertrand l' inverse n'étant pas
vrai
pour l'instant à date à date xavier
bertrand n'a jamais dit qu'il
s'effacerait derrière le candidat qui
sortiraient de la primaire dlr et qui
ferait 1 1 et qu'ils feraient avec toi
un meilleur sort que lui dans les
sondages donc ça vous embête voilà c'est
ça va être ça va complexifier un peu les
choses
bien que on politise tout peut arriver
disons que ce qui se fait ces cas
actuellement on a des candidats
extrêmement convaincu temps valérie
pécresse que xavier bertrand dont ils
sont dans dans leur leur expression
d'une candidature aux présidentielles
ils y vont à fond parce qu'ils y croient
fouet en tout cas valérie pécresse six
fois à phu est donc le moment venu
évidemment il y aura il y aura
évidemment
dialogue et négociation pour que le
meilleur d'entre eux soit candidat
est ce qu'on peut imaginer au bout du
compte un ticket finalement
aquatique et xavier bertrand valérie
pécresse
oui dans quel sens ce vin c'est celle
mégane 1
le mega man et
ce beaucoup de ministres en deux
vous marchez avec de fer et nadège
france 169,8 j'avais fait de
550 m ont donné que c'est quand même
quelques quelques mois quand même là et
il peut se passer beaucoup de choses
donc un mois je chante adam mair je
pense qu'il fait un problème dans le
débat qu'on a actuellement c'est qu'on a
parlé au début de l'abstention il
problèmes que les gens n'arrivent pas à
se connecter à la politique est
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on fait là
c'est au débat là on parle de personnes
on parle de balle et deux personnes en
parallèle au grade mais une fois des
idées mais de près ces débats là en tant
que tel c'est le fait que les français
en tant que tel dans les débats qui voit
aujourd'hui ses débats de personnes y
voit on va se battre entre eux entre
pécresse entre tous les différents noms
et je pense qu'on n'y beaucoup à la
politique quand on parle pas vraiment de
la vie des gens là on parle pas de la
vie des gens on parle de ça on parle de
deggo finalement est de savoir qui va
devenir le futur président de la
république et je pense qu'on y perd
beaucoup être présenté cette présente
présidentialisation de la vie politique
c'est vrai mais c'est le système comme
ça va oui mais il faut aussi répondre
aux vrais problèmes de vie des français
il faut aussi parler des programmes
avant tout et ce qui est important pour
les français c'est les les lois qu'on va
faire passer est pas forcément
leader mais ça passe par une incarnation
élection présidentielle oui bien sûr
élections qui a encore un petit peu
d'ouvriers et voilà que tu passes dans
l'incarnation effectivement une dizaine
vers rio s'est joué là c'est celle de
l'élection où les gens croient quelque
chose aussi parce que les français juste
et donc pas ce que j'aurais camdeborde
mais c'est vraiment conclure il reste
moins de deux minutes
justement sur les anti pacs est le
complice de j'ai une question à vous
poser
[Musique]
on parlait tout à l'air de on a corsé
l'addition avec l'abstention c'est vrai
qu il ya un certain nombre de mouvements
ge dans son gilet jaune je pense aux
anti vaccins qui n'ont aucune
représentation politique
hier les candidats gilet jaune qui se
sont présentés il faut un pour cent de
bourses aux trois morceaux au maximum
est ce que on n'est pas dans une société
où justement il ya la politique d'un
côté et puis des mouvements de l'autre
qui n'en ont rien à faire de ce qui se
passe ce sont des mouvements totalement
hétéroclite qui se sont fait de
rassemblement de personnes qui n'ont pas
les mêmes intérêts et non pas les mêmes
envies qu'on pas les mêmes besoins mais
qui se retrouvent autour d'un certain
mécontentement sur une question donnée
qu'elle soit démocratique qu'elle soit
que ce soit la vaccination où que ce
soit autre chose ça ça tient au fait
aussi que moi je crois beaucoup qu'on
n'a pas suffisamment tout cela
collectivement étudier cette fameuse
diagonale du ville dont les géographes
parvient depuis des années des années et
cette espèce de métropolisation à
outrance qu'on a fait c'est à dire qu'on
a envoyé tous pas seulement l'économie
mais la culture le sport enfin tous vers
les métropoles et les métropoles nous
ont toujours dit ne vous inquiétez pas
ça reviendra chez vous un jour on a bien
vu que ce n'était jamais revenu il faut
impérativement s'occuper j'aime pas
j'aime pas opposer ruralité et métropole
mais en tout cas les il faut s'occuper
des territoires oubliés oublier lier ça
ça devrait être une un des sujets de la
campagne présidentielle à venir remettre
de la vie de l'économie alors que bourg
en a parlé oui oui
celle il faut que les gens s'emparent de
ça on voit bien que quand on réussit je
prends l'association l'opération mille
cafés quand on réussit à réintroduire
des commerces dans des petits bourgs de
moins de 1000 habitants et bien
finalement une espèce de bien-être rené
et ça fait forcément baisser la
contestation bon voilà malheureusement
là le temps qui nous est imparti tout le
monde y est mais on va pas les aider
vous reviendrez avec avec plaisir de
débattre et puis on se retrouve très
vite pour une nouvelle émission de poste
merci à tous
[Musique]